I really look exceptionally ghostly
today
what happened
just got my hand on and so because my
hair is white effectively my camera
doesn't know how to color balance and
here we are a dead woman walking hello
everybody I'm a lot of welcome to
another episode of good gaming news
which is a weekly show where I talk
about all the good news to come out of
video games because there are enough
people on YouTube talking about the bad
news I do now cover the biggest news of
the day in YouTube shorts and that
includes whatever the biggest stories
which can be bad news but this is a
weekly show where we just celebrate
video games it doesn't get as many views
but it makes us feel good there's a lot
to love about gaming even if technically
the first story is like a response to
something really bad that keeps
happening and gaming the stories from
games industry top Biz and said European
Parliament votes to take action against
loot boxes gaming addiction gold farming
and more commission will also set up a
European video game strategy to grow
industry and a European video game award
I guess why not everybody's gonna have
an award show says the woman who created
her own awards show the minds for
accessibility it's different the story
is one that I have been
um frankly reporting on for probably
almost an entire decade we were covering
stories like this at IGN we were
covering stories like this at the outlet
that I worked at before I worked at IGN
and it is something that uh feels to me
like it is inevitable
um the world just didn't really know how
to catch up to the tech of video games
because frankly a lot of what
um these video game companies are doing
is extremely shady and I have ongoing
concerns where games of service is
concerned but we'll get to that the
story says the European Parliament voted
today to adopt a report calling for the
European commission to address several
issues in the games industry that it
believes will better protect consumers
especially young people the report was
led by MEP Adriana Maldonado Lopez and
secured 577 votes in favor fail more
than a dozen recommendations included in
the report including a call for
harmonized rules across the European
Union single Market when providing clear
information about games content which is
I think pretty important including
monetization strategies that should
include also like games of service that
should include battle passes 100 of the
uh content like that that yes we can say
is optional as much as we want to and I
say that as somebody who has not once
ever bought a battle pass proudly I will
not do it for the Publishers publishing
these games are aware that when you buy
a game that has a battle pass and they
say it's it's optional they know that
their players are going to be like oh
what's this content that I borrowed from
in this online multiplayer experience I
can't play this map because I don't know
this is better possible where'd you get
that skin they're not stupid it's barely
optional we have to be realistic about
how powerful coercion is in marketing
and um I'm of the opinion that consumers
do not actually have as much
self-control as we would all like to
think and that we are very easily swayed
by marketing
and that that doesn't make us dumb it's
just that a single individual human
certainly struggles to compete against
several multi-billion dollar Industries
we don't really stand a chance Harry
Potter also included recommendations
that would help parents understand and
control how much time and money their
children spend on games and I think we
would be hard-pressed to find anybody
who thinks that that's a bad idea MEPS
are also voted to have the commission
analyze the impact of loot boxes and
prompts to make in-game purchases taking
action if necessary as well as
investigating whether gold farming can
be linked to financial crimes and human
rights abuses they also call for
developers to avoid designing games that
feed addiction with Lopez citing the
who's recognition of gaming disorder as
an example of the state of addiction
among some players that one I feel is a
little bit more complicated I know the
kinds of games that I get addicted to
I'm aware that I have had a rule for a
pretty long time where I will not play
an MMO I cannot play MMOs it is
dangerous for me I will genuinely suffer
from whose actual definition of gaming
disorder where I will just lose my life
I won't sleep I won't eat I will just
play an MMO and that's the case for a
lot of people who play MMOs and saying
that they are designed to be addictive
is a little bit complicated otherwise
not necessarily designed to be addictive
they are more designed and I think MMOs
is such an interesting one because so
much of what you do in a memo is just
click you just click a button that is
not actually satisfying
they are designed to give you a sense of
satisfaction to make you feel like you
are accomplishing something when you get
the level up when you put the new armor
on when you unlock the new smell
did I say smell I meant spell
you feel a sense of accomplishment and
thus validation I feel like that is
exemplified in a social video game like
an MMO do I feel like MMOs are designed
in a way that is
um intentionally dangerously feeding
addiction no that's just player
satisfaction and enjoyment which again I
think that's a really complicated thing
for an organization to try to figure out
how to address and how to limit there
are some probably egregious examples
like mobile games
but for the most part that's a really
tough one and I'm not looking forward to
watching them have that conversation I
don't think a good video game is uh
dangerously addictive any more than a
good TV show could be considered
dangerously addictive uh other actions
though recommended including a
prioritizing data protection improving
the gender imbalance on the industry's
workforce and making it as easy for
consumers to cancel a subscription as it
is to sign up which I would love to see
everywhere across the board yes please
at the same time and this is like extra
good news inside of the story The
European Parliament recognized the value
of the video game sector as well as its
potential to help with education mental
health and other aspects of life which
is awesome we so rarely see like any
form of government admit that video
games uh have these extremely beneficial
outcomes as well that that uh playing
video games can be tremendously good for
your mental health and for cognitive
ability and for your social life for
other aspects of life so the Mbps have
asked the European commission to devise
European video game strategy that would
boost the industry and help unlock its
full potential all while seemingly being
aware of loot boxes and poor
monetization strategies love that
they also propose the creation of a new
annual European online video game award
which again
why I don't know
but I but as part of this ahead of the
vote the interactive software Federation
of Europe and the European gain
developers Federation issued a joint
statement saying the two trade bodies
were concerned by calls with stricter
regulation of all in-game purchases he
had no [ __ ] you were concerned that's
where you make money the player said
such regulation will impact the ability
of all games firms to fund development
all all but yes generally um there is a
bunch more to this that I will link to
in case you want to read more on this
story
um I'm just glad to see it being talked
about honestly next up wanted to jump to
two very quick little tidbits here the
first one is that games Done Quick which
if you haven't heard of it is
effectively like a charity live
streaming event where people try to
speedrun and finish games as quickly as
possible it's super fun to watch um I
watch it every single year this year
they raised a total of 2 million 642
493 dollars
for prevent cancer which is awesome they
said thanks to everyone who made this
Marathon possible and to all of you for
your amazing generosity and support see
you all next time at sgdq 2023 from May
28th to June 4th and yeah you'd love to
see it just great news that's really all
I have to say about that one very happy
about it there is another quick one here
actually
um while we're on it just the fact that
Persona 3 and Persona 4 Golden are now
available on other platforms which is
awesome news I actually went to atlas's
um celebration party for this last night
it was really fun they had a Persona
drone light show that was pretty rad
both great games big fan of persona love
that they're actually becoming more
available on more platforms except IGN
go out to an exclusive uh Deep dive
interview about Silent Hill 2 remake
which if you're like me you think it's
one of the best games on the planet I
love Silent Hill too so much you are
potentially concerned but also quite
excited to find out a little bit more
information about the Silent Hill 2
remake really hope they don't [ __ ] it up
that's all I'm saying story comes from
IGN and says after years of speculation
it was finally announced on October's
Silent Hill transmission live stream
that the Silent Hill series will get a
multi-project reboot while the Showcase
revealed several games and even a new
movie it began with the news that the
first title in the return of the series
would be a full remake of Silent Hill 2
by bluba team the Polish Studio known
for games like layers of fear and the
medium IGN Japan had the opportunity to
interview the series producer and
concept artist
um who worked on the original series but
are also actually working on the
blueberton series which hopefully makes
a lot of people feel a lot more
comforted well and IGN asked the two how
they feel about uh how blue the team
Works okamoto said to begin with
Bluebird team is amazingly talented at
creating environments you can really
experience what James is feeling just by
walking through the foggy town I think
the excellent at making backgrounds
environments and atmosphere on top of
that are putting a lot of tension into
combat in order to make the gameplay
that much deeper I see them as very hard
workers who are full of love for Silent
Hill which is obviously great news and
Idol said personally I'm very satisfied
with the quality of the town and the
atmosphere of this Silent Hill to
they're making I really get the feeling
that they respect the original while
still making sure to arrange things in
their own way in particular we had
strong demands about the motif of fog
once first starting on this remake and
they were sure to depict it just as we
wanted I believe from the bottom of my
heart that they're making something
incredible and clearly this is a very
close collaboration basically what it
sounds like um is that Konami internally
was like hey we want to bring Silent
Hill back and there were so many games
coming out that were seeing success that
were inspired by Silent Hill they were
like okay how do we do this using
external Talent which is why they
obviously partnered with a bunch of
Indie Studios but they are Partnerships
basically it sounds like it's super
collaborative like Konami is working
very very closely with each of these
Indie Studios to make sure that silent
Hill feels like Silent Hill it's not
just completely outsourced which is
great yamoka said I play Blueberry teams
games myself and as game developed as we
can tell just how much they love Silent
Hill it's more than just love too I
sense a strong respect for the title and
they exceed my expectations I think that
when it's done the game will be one made
with real thought about how to bring it
back in this day and age and I think
they also did speak about how they don't
want to just direct remake it they
wanted to like when bringing Silent Hill
2 back into the world
um in a modern context figure out where
Silent Hill actually fits in a modern
context and part of that was that they
they were thinking about what actually
makes Silent Hill Silent Hill and said
that they think it's kind of the
Pinnacle of psychological horror for
video games and I would agree with that
and it sounds like they are recognizing
that as like the core of the brand and
really making sure they lean into that
across all of the Silent Hill games that
are going to come out which to me is
very comforting for all the games that
have been inspired by Silent Hill I
still don't know if anyone has actually
managed to top them they said here that
this will be the first time that they
actually Implement uh the Japanese voice
acting
and I hope to do so will make Japanese
players feel an even stronger sense of
familiar diary with Silent Hill 2 I
might even play it in Japanese just for
fun it's another interesting tidbit here
is that they decided to
what are you doing
he has a vote I'm sorry they said they
decided to raise James's age in the game
a bit this is in part because fans from
20 years ago are older now and because
the average age of people who play video
games has risen too we want to depict a
James who is more mature and has had to
suffer through more in his life and to
do that we raise his age though only by
a bit if he looks old to you it's not
your imagination which I suppose he does
this is super interesting okamoto said
you couldn't depict skin in a nuanced
way during the PS2 era everyone ended up
looking younger or at least had smooth
skin what a fun tidbit like you kind of
couldn't do age back then in terms of
new elements they said more immersive
camera of course which will really up
the atmosphere hopefully improve combat
design while respecting the original
design so they're not changing too much
about the way the monsters move and act
and they'll have just some improvements
to enemies as well enemy AI being remade
from the ground up so there is a ton
more detail in this one as well I'll
leave a link in the description if you
want to read more but I basically pulled
out what I thought would be the most
interesting to you guys finally to fun
pretty short stories first one is that
return all is launching on PC February
15. I love this game a I think house
milk are fantastic I think her tunnel
was brilliant it was one of my favorite
games of the year when it came out and
this is this is captured on PC it's
already graphically stunning so just
excited for anyone who hasn't played it
yet to get to play it now that it's come
to PC and finally this one's just very
up my alley I don't know how many other
people are going to be interested in
this but I am pumped about it and it
just made me so excited for like
potential futures
um this is from future lab uh we'll
watch this trailer because I actually
haven't watched it yet I just saw the
news announcement again sorry about the
dog playing with this bone in the
background
are you enjoying yourself back here bud
hey banjo can you balk if you like good
gaming news
good boy so this is from future lab and
says power wash simulated Nintendo
switch and PS4 slash 5 release date plus
Tomb Raider special Pack trailer this
sounds so cool
it's a good idea
such a good idea
[Music]
because oh
and in theory like can I do this on like
the Nostromo like alien packs was what
um when Austin texted me about this
that's what he suggested like in theory
anything and unreal I think is what
they're running on you could just get
some assets and start power washing in
all these different universes it's so
cool that is it for me and this week
everybody again I'm now doing like
regular gaming news that's outside of
this positive show as YouTube shorts so
one minute a day trying to keep up with
those I won't do them if they're like
isn't a big news story but I'm having
fun with that so um check those out on
the channel and
and uh otherwise I will see you for more
good gaming news next week bye